turn now to politics and it is primary
election day across Nevada and for the
first time ever you cannot vote in
person anywhere in Clark County
Janka Holmen live at one of the many
locations though where you can still
drop off your ballot today hi Bianca hey
good morning Alex
the elections were moved to mail-in to
help slow down the spread of the corona
virus so you got to get that ballot in
the mail today by the time the post
office closed or you can bring it to a
drop-off location like here at the
windmill library and you would drop it
off here just like you would if you were
returning a book now here goes some
information about the drop offs and
about the election in general there's a
lot of important races on the ballot all
four congressional races are up for
grabs the incumbents are all expected to
win their primaries but national
Republicans seat Nevada's 3rd and 4th
districts currently held by Democrats
Suzie Lee and Steven Horsford as ones
they might be able to flip in November
Clark County Commission seats C and D
are also up for grabs along with Supreme
Court seats lower court judges school
board members and several state assembly
and Senate races
today's vote will decide which
candidates will advance to the general
election in November now you should have
gotten a ballot in the mail a few weeks
ago after you vote seal it with a pre
address postage paid return envelope
sign in the area provided then get it
into the mail by the time the post
office closes tonight and if not you can
of course take it to a county drop-off
box many of them open until 7 p.m. and
we've got that full list on our website
at 8 News now.com now the candidates
that when today will go into the general
election in November and there's no yet
work no word yet on if that election is
going to be mail-in like this one or if
you're going to go in and and cast your
ballot at one of the machines like we
normally do that's yet to be determined
reporting live from windmill and rainbow
Bianca Holman 8 News now